[Music]
love is in the air for your favorite
stars
Kim and Kanye pack on the PDA Max and
PETA enjoyed a family snuggle together
with hashtag baby Chmerkovskiy and
Michelle Obama played footsie on the
beach with her favorite Island mate her
hubby Brock Miley Cyrus wished her fans
a love evey day by photoshopping her
love Liam Hemsworth in her red dress the
couple spent the romantic day by the
beach with who else and her dogs her
message is simple try your very best to
make sure everyone you come in contact
with today feels extra special how's
this cuteness Scott Disick's Valentine
is his daughter Penelope gigi hadid is
keeping boyfriend zayn malik close
rocking his tea in New York while pink
shared this throwback photo with husband
Carey Hart
she wrote I've been loving for you so
long I don't remember what it's like not
to and for all you lonely hearts out
there fear not
John Mayer's got your back if you have
an Instagram crush tag them in the
captions below if you are and it's the
gram crush that has been tagged in the
captions below this song is for you
sound that is stalking you somebody
wants to talk to you somebody wants to
take a walk with you
[Music]
you